viele menschen sehnen sich danach die
zwänge des berufslebens hinter sich
lassen zu können
sie wünschen sich unabhängig von
vorgesetzten zu sein mehr zu reisen
auszuschlafen und zu arbeiten wann und
wo sie es möchte genau das soll die
internetseite fall möglich machen ohne
ausbildung und zertifikate habe ich mich
dort vor sieben tagen angemeldet und
versucht innerhalb von einer woche
möglichst viel geld von zu hause aus zu
verdienen in dieser fortsetzung werde
ich dokumentieren wie ich auch die
nächsten drei wochen auf fall weil die
verrücktesten aufträge ausführen um
herauszufinden welches monatseinkommen
ich mit selbständiger arbeit auf fall
war
zusätzlich zu meinem eigentlichen
vollzeitberuf erwirtschaften kann
dieses video wird von safe disk
unterstützt der software die steuern und
buchhaltung endlich erträglich macht es
ist jetzt drei tage her seitdem ich das
letzte mal auftrat und wir haben über
das wochenende wirklich viele aufträge
bekommen wie schon erwartet hat das
einfach ein bisschen gedauert bis die
bewertungen bekommen dass wir kunden
vorgeschlagen werden und bis der ball
ins rollen kommen ich werde mich jetzt
mal als erstes um den ganzen neuen
aufträge kümmern
einer möchte einen retro fit für 100
euro ein anderer möchte einen sommer
später auch für 100 euro
und wieder ein anderer möchte einen
farbfilter bei dem man die deckkraft
durch das tippen auf das display ändern
kann
für 60 euro das bedeutet wir haben viel
zu tun aber anders als beim ersten teil
dieser reihe werde ich nicht jede freie
sekunde investieren sondern das ganze
einfach entspannten nebenbei neben
meinem eigentlichen beruf machen für den
ich schon circa 80 stunden pro woche
investieren
heute muss ich aber noch den ganzen tag
am video für nächste woche arbeiten
deswegen müssen die aufträge bis morgen
warten
wir haben heute einen straffen zeitplan
ich hab mir vier stunden für fall war
eingeplant und nicht guckt jetzt noch
mal wie viel ich in dieser zeit schafft
ich beginne mit etwas leichter er könnte
hätte gerne dass ich ihm ein leid von
presets in ein instagram filter
konvertierte und zeit dafür 40 euro der
prozess ist relativ simpel so dass ich
nach circa 40 minuten fertig bin und in
meine arbeit schicke anders sieht es bei
meinem nächsten auftrag für 60 euro aus
es ist auch hier wieder ein einfacher
farbfilter jedoch möchte der kunde
zwischen vier verschiedenen deckkraft
stufen auswählen können das wovon ich
dachte das ist einfach wäre
ist doch relativ kompliziert und zwingt
mich dazu den rest des tages javascript
zu studieren leider ohne erfolg
wir haben wir dann einen saftigen
auftrag im postfach dieser version hätte
gerne einen einfachen zugang vertreter
wieder für 40 euro aber bevor wir damit
anfangen können kümmere ich mich jetzt
erst mal um die bestehenden aufträge
hier geht es um einen retro look filter
dieser filter besteht aus einer
verarbeitung einem rahmen rauschen
flackern und diversen flecken
übereinander gelagert es dauert einige
zeit bis ich alle einzelelemente
zusammen gesammelt habe und es dauert
noch länger bis sich alle elemente
zusammen gebastelt habe zudem prototypen
den ich nach ungefähr drei stunden an
den kunden sind wir gerade anfrage von
teilweise deutschland betreuen das ist
glaube ich das deutsche social media
team von fall war
und die hätten gerne einen weihnachts
filter was ziemlich geil ist dass die
milch und anfragen
ich glaube aber für so größere firmen
wäre es dann sinnvoller das thema e mail
zu regeln weil also wenn jetzt eine
firma so einfällt drucken würde wäre das
ja in der regel immer über 1000 euro und
ich weiß nicht wann ich da bock habt 20
prozent anteile abzugeben
im letzten teil der fall weise haben wir
ja einige aufträge auch aussehen so
genannten fireworks gefunden wir
brauchen jetzt gerade zwei gar keine
aufträge mehr weil de viel zu tun aber
ich fand es ziemlich witzig und deswegen
lese ich mir die erstmal durch weiß das
gibt an aufträgen werden
der minecraft bauer gesetz auf gall
er will dass man auch sein aus einen
tick tock video falschen drauf animiert
starb stark ja für 12 dollar
schade dass wir einfach keine zeit haben
ich arbeite jetzt mal wieder an den
alten aufträgen weiter obwohl ich mir
vorgenommen habe fall war nur entspannt
nebenbei zu machen nimmt es mehr zeit in
anspruch als erwartet und sorgt für
zusätzlichen stress meistens weil dinge
nicht auf anhieb funktionieren die man
es denkt ich setzen sie das seit über
einer stunde an dem skript für den
internet filter mit dem weg kraftstoffen
und er ist es also 16 verzweifeln ich
komme einfach kein bisschen weiter und
es funktioniert wirklich ganz einfach
ohne grund nicht mehr ist ich hab keine
ahnung so ist nicht funktioniert weil es
sollte eigentlich funktionieren tut aber
einfach nicht
ich lege mich trotzdem ins bett ist
schon spät gute nacht es atmet langsam
wirklich ein bisschen aus wie haben noch
vier aktive aufträge und gerade kann
schon wieder neuer rein um den ein
bisschen entgegen zu wirken wenn ich
jetzt mal die preise erhöhen damit wir
noch weniger anfragen trägen aber
trotzdem vor dem ziel mehr geld und ich
werde auch die lieferzeiten deutlich
erholen damit ich mir einfach dass ein
bisschen besser einteilen kann zwar
nicht die aufträge gemacht und wenn ich
die aufträgt abgeben und dann einfach
nicht so viel stress habe ich führe
gerade noch kleine änderungen aus sie
sich der kunde des retro fürchtete
wünschen hat anschließend mache ich mich
an die arbeit für den sommersprossen
filter
sollte der filter der weit auch wieder
ein bisschen komplizierter das problem
ist dass wir ja beides einmal das
gesicht retuschieren und zweitens die
sommersprossen auch das gesicht anwenden
und diese beiden ebenen haben sich in
dem programm ein bisschen gebissen aber
ich habe eine lösung gefunden auch wenn
es ein bisschen gedauert hat und der
kunde hat sie den filter auch schon
angenommen und deshalb wieder mit und
und wurden auch schon bereits 100 euro
gutgeschrieben wieder frei war und
meinen eigentlichen beruf unter einen
hut zu bringen klappt einigermaßen aber
es ist sehr wichtig keine zu kurzen
lieferzeiten anzubieten damit man sich
alles ordentlich einteilen kann das
schreckt natürlich einige kunden ab aber
ich denke mittlerweile können wir uns
das leisten da ich eh keine zeit habe
für noch mehr kunden kleines update ihr
könnt euch ja bestimmt auch an den
problemfelder erinnern mit der deckkraft
auswahl da ich das wirklich nicht
hingekriegt habe ich jetzt eine
alternative vorgeschlagen wie sogar
besser ist und zwar kann man jetzt
einfach über 4 button zieht der kraft
auswählt und der kunde ist damit auch
sehr sehr happy und für den extra
aufwand mit den knöpfen haben wir
zusätzlich zu den 60 euro noch 30 euro
obendrauf verdient haben und auch noch
ein richtig lustigen auftrag gekriegt
indem wir die augen des nutzers das
filter nutzer ist durch spieler ersetzen
darum werde ich morgen kümmert der kunde
mit in super 8 verdacht heute noch eine
kleine extra änderung abgefragt das
werde ich ihm aber dementsprechend auch
extra den rechnung bestellen weil es
eine zwei gebuchten korrektur schleifen
ja schon verbraucht sind hier haben wir
zusätzlich zu den 100 euro also noch mal
fünf euro extra verdienen der monat ist
erst zur hälfte vorbei und ich bin echt
gespannt wie viel wir bis zum ende
verdient haben und was aus dem auftrag
wird den wir von fall berichts
persönlich bekommen haben wie einige
unter meinem letzten fall video schon zu
recht gefragt haben gehen von allem was
wir hier jetzt verdienen natürlich
nochmal steuern weg zwar muss man sofern
man 2009 10 unter 9168 euro verdient hat
keine einkommensteuer zahlen
aber man muss dem finanzamt trotzdem
haargenau beweisen dass man auch ja
keinen einzelnen cent zu viel verdient
hat in anderen worten als selbständiger
kommt man einfach nicht dran vorbei egal
wie wenigen und verdient sich um dieses
leidige thema zu kümmern und anstatt wie
man das normalmaß stundenlang vor einem
berg teuflischen papierkram zu sitzen
scansafe das ganz einfach belege per app
ein oder welt sie von seinem computer
aus selbst liest automatisch alle
wichtigen informationen aus dem dokument
kategorisiert direkt alle belege der
einnahmen und ausgaben und bietet an der
einnahmen überschussrechnung sowie
weitere statistiken in echtzeit die
software erstellt in sekundenschnelle
professionelle rechnungen und kann sogar
die umsatzsteuervoranmeldung direkt ans
finanzamt schicken also wenn ihr selbst
wenn ich zeit und auch wenn ihr gerade
ist damit anfangen dann checkt ein link
in dem video beschreibungen aus und
testet das gratis 14 tage
und wenn ihr besonders schnell seid
könnt ihr zum jahreswechsel selbst ist
sogar sechs monate kostenlos benutzen
das social media team welches jahren ein
auftritt für mich hatte das hat sich
leider nicht mehr bei mir gemeldet
schade eigentlich wie versprochen setzen
wir uns heute an den spiegel väter und
auch hier frage ich mich wieder werte
zahlen für sowas eigentlich geld aber
ich glaube für 45 euro kann ich mich
nicht beschweren also los geht's als
erstes würde ich mir ein bild von einem
spiel gleich und schneit es aus dann
setze ich das spiel noch auf die augen
des filter nutzers der fitte wer jetzt
schon fast fertig aber mit so was lustig
ist eingefallen ich nicht viel besser
wenn ich spiele ein größe durch das
öffnen des mundes eingestellt wird und
deswegen deswegen stehe ich dem kunden
einfach beide versionen weihnachten
rückt immer näher und ich bin deswegen
schon mega im vorproduktion stress
aktuell
ich habe aktuell wieder einige aufträge
am start muss aber auch ganz ehrlich
zugeben dass es wirklich sehr sehr
schwierig ist meinen kunden genug
aufmerksamkeit zu schenken und deren
deadlines einzuhalten also dass sie
gerade erlebt ich gar nicht gut aus und
es tut mir wirklich leid für die kunden
die das ganze zeit ausbauen müssen
heute ist der zweite weihnachtsfeiertag
als oder 26.12.10 und ich habe die
letzten tage viel zeit mit meiner
familie und meinen freunden verbracht
und bin dementsprechend extrem gar nicht
dazu gekommen nicht um eine falle
aufträge zu kümmern wenn man auf fall
war unzufrieden ist dann kann man einen
so genannten disput einreichen
und das haben ganze drei leute bei mir
gemacht weil ich eben nicht innerhalb
der deutschland abgeliefert habe was
natürlich nicht okay ist mit zwei davon
habe ich das klären können die haben es
dann verstanden aber der andere der der
meldet sich leider nicht es ist jetzt 23
uhr und ich wollte eigentlich mit meinen
freunden feiern gehen aber ich glaube
ich sollte mich wohl oder übel mal und
meine aufträge kümmern während andere
zeit mit ihrer familie verbringen und
meine freunde gerade im club spaß haben
sich alleine an meinem pc und arbeiter
so ziemlich jeder arbeitnehmer hat
weihnachtsfeiertag frei und arbeitet
schon gleich gar nicht um 23 uhr nachts
aber das sind die schattenseiten die man
unter umständen in kauf nehmen muss wenn
man sich den traum der selbständigkeit
erfüllen möchte heute ist der letzte tag
der 28 cent
in wenigen stunden kommt dieses video
online und wir haben jetzt im dezember
mit 828 882 euro verdient wenn er wissen
möchte wie viel ich mit youtube verdient
habt dann klickt auf den link in dem
video beschreibung da hab ich euch ein
video von meinem zweiten mal verlinkt
mit dieser summe an geld und dem relativ
geringen zeitaufwand sind jetzt wirklich
an dem punkt angekommen wo es sich für
viele menschen und gerade für studenten
oder für schüler über 16 jahre aber auch
für menschen die aktuell arbeiten und
zusätzlich noch nach der arbeit energie
haben keine sich lohnen um sich extra
was zu verdienen oder aber auch um den
übergang zur selbstständigkeit zu
schaffen während sie gerade noch in
einer sicheren festanstellung sind wenn
wir euch steuern und jegliche andere
papierkram genauso viel angst auslöst
wie bei mir
dann klick auf den link in der video
beschreibung und feste zepter ist gratis
pro 14 tage um papierkram deutlich
leichter unerträglicher und schneller
und effizienter zu machen nicht alles
fast jede woche ein video wie dieses
hoch also wenn ihr mich auf dieser reise
begleiten möchte dann abonniert gerne
diesen kanal und dann sehen wir zunächst
mal wieder
[Musik]